[Music]
your latest book goes back to the
principles underlying philosophy and
philosophy undergraduates are famously
quite confused the more philosophy they
read and the more philosophy they try to
understand but to us we can also clear
up our minds is the confusion part of
the solution or how did the two work I
don't think being confused is a solution
to to any problem that that I know but I
I'm not sure that philosophy students
are more confused than students in other
areas necessarily I mean they're they're
finding the material that they're
working with quite difficult to
understand because it is it is very
demanding
but at the same time the fact that they
can that they're confused is a sign that
they are actually engaging with it
properly the the really bad sign is when
you get somebody who sort of quickly
skims through pages of difficult
philosophy and and and thinks that
they've understood it completely and
that tells you that they've understood
nothing nothing at all
so you know confusion is a natural
reaction to the difficult process of
thinking things through in a deeper way
than the new you're used to and with a
bit of luck if something sometimes leads
to too much a clear a state of mind at
the at the end and I'm plenty of
students that I teach her to do to get
to that kind of clarity about what about
everything but a lot of things so how
can philosophy help us think clearer
more clearly well philosophy gives you a
kind of toolkit for thinking about
issues very very general kinds of so
that for example you just you learn
things like distinguishing between
necessary conditions and sufficient
conditions and the sort of thing is it
that you
just get in the habit when people start
talking about one thing being a
condition for another you know you ask
yourself are they talking about
necessary conditions or sufficient
conditions and and so you you learn to
distinguish different different things
that they might be saying and work out
which one they all say or maybe we
realize that that they're confused which
between the the two and you have a kind
of checklist of of things that you
control for when when you're when you're
reading and and that can brings out the
contours of what somebody's saying a bit
more clearly than than if you just sort
of read through it with glazed eyes with
without very much attempt to kind of
analyze it and it gives you so you know
some skill in noticing what what
assumptions people are making in their
arguments which conclusions and and
which things they're just conjecturing
and which they're asserting and you just
alright expect you to make these kind of
distinctions
oh of course every doctor does some of
this but I think philosophy does it a
bit more and a bit more systematically
than others and and then there was a
recent study that was showing that
actually and ethics professors are not
necessarily more ethical in their
personal lives and I was wondering
whether the same happens with logic
professors that they're not necessarily
more rational or more logical in their
personal and maybe political lives and
beliefs what's your perception of that
well I think when you study logic you
realize that there are what the limits
of logic are apart from anything else
and of course most most questions in
ethics and politics cannot be solved by
logic alone and I think the tendency
amounts logicians is if if there's ever
a weakness it's that they they tend to
be a little bit paralyzed with my
questions
which can't be solved by by logic alone
but but it that doesn't mean that they
can be solved by ignoring logic and
logic is important one of the things
that you need at least in dealing with
complex problems so you don't really
need it for simple ones and but it's got
to be combined with with various kinds
of knowledge from outside logic in for
example some ability independently of
logic to recognize that these simple
cases of right and wrong so logic is one
instrument but it's not the only
instrument to solve those issues could
you and give an example of how logic is
helpful even in a political or a
personal situation but it needs
something else to actually solve the
issue well the things the situations
that where logic is useful tend to be
and where as well formal logic is useful
tend to be more complex ones and
everything I think rather going into
going into the complexities of other
particular political problems or
whatever because I don't I don't think
that oh if we taught politicians a
little bit of formal logic then they
would easily solve the present problem
or anything like that but I think the
clearest example of the practical value
of logic is that the Alan Turing who
many people know from the imitation game
and he was solving a very abstract
problem in logic called the decision
problem and as a result of that he
invented the computer I mean initially
just as really has an idea and not not
as something that
with existed concrete reality but of
course when the Second World War came
along and that was the need to break the
German codes he then built a machine
according to the abstract design and
that was the origin of the the modern
computer so that's that's a very simple
way in which logic has have made an
enormous practical difference I I can't
say that that when I'm solving personal
problems I I list some premises and then
deduce a conclusion as to what I should
do it's it's wrong it's before a direct
its logic than just a tool you use in
your work or does it actually overflow
into other fields of your life as well
well I think I don't think of it as just
a tool I think that the principles of
logic that they're not just linguistic
rules they're actually in some way laws
of reality and and so in studying logic
you are actually studying the world in
in its most abstract general structural
features so so that I if you like
logical knowledge is valuable and some
an end as well as a means as my my wife
would agree that when it comes to
solving my own personal problems I hope
that logic doesn't help very much and
you're a strong believer in debate in
the role of debate in analytic
philosophy and I was wondering if you
could make the case for it
well I think every debate arises because
people disagree and
and then rather than using violence or
something to settle their their
disagreement we have to in some way
compare these opposing views and and
discover the strengths and weaknesses of
them and I don't think you can really do
that without you know on the one hand
having people who will prepare to
strongly defender of you and on the
other hand have have people who are
doing their best to think of objections
to it so it took just this is what you
sometimes see in philosophy conferences
and I mean there are kind of rules to
some extent of fair and foul play in
these these debates and and it isn't
just a matter of it's all to do with
personal animus it's really to do with
with testing the strengths of a theory
to to see what kind of challenges it can
overcome what what things it can explain
which may be it initially looked hard to
explain and and and where it doesn't
really have an answer to their kinds of
question and and I think the the best
way of discovering the strengths and
weaknesses is by as I say by having
people who are strongly motivated on
each side to do them in one case to do
the very best they can for the theory
and in the other case to do the very the
very worst that they can to be the
theory where and I think it's it's just
a predictable fact about human nature
that people tend not to be very good at
seeing the the faults in their own views
so you have to get somebody else to do
it for you the critics of the debate
style of analytic philosophy associate
this culture with a mulching of
masculine culture and they say that
maybe because of this kind combative
style of analytic philosophy
female philosophers or philosophers from
ethnic minorities might feel less
confident in joining a debate how would
you respond to that well I mean one
thing is that that some of the most
effective debaters in philosophy that
I've known have beaten have been women I
mean people like Ruth Barkin Marcus ray
Langton Delia Graf fara Judith Jarvis
Thompson and so on I mean they have been
really tough debaters and and of course
it's true that for for people lacking in
self-confidence there it is difficult to
put your hand up and ask a question and
see what what kind of response it gets
and and so I mean we do have to be to be
careful that the philosophical culture
is is one where everybody is treated
with with respect and one thing that
that was the case of one time is that
the probably the questions asked by by
women and by people from ethnic
minorities were somehow given given less
weight than the questions asked by my
white men and I mean I I hope that that
is just no longer the the case I think
there are just too many examples of
people who are not white but men will
who who are very respected in the
profession and everybody knows that if
they ask a question you you really have
to be you know we're on top for them to
answer it properly because it is not
going to be an easy question so you know
I think I think that was more a matter
of prejudices that were that were right
in the general culture I'm not
disappearing when you got into the
philosophy conference or classroom and
and I think old although of course those
prejudice not totally disappeared but I
think they are that the much less
prevalent than they than they were and
of course you know I think also that as
the proportion of women and people from
ethnic minorities in philosophy
increases that there's less danger of of
marginalization but you know I I think
it is also the case that debating in in
public is a scary experience because
you're you're putting your ideas on the
line and the whole point of it is that
idea should be probably be tested but
that you can mean that your ideas are
found wanting in public and I mean you'd
have to be a very strange kind of person
really to enjoy that one thing that we
ask and the speakers at the festival is
whether there's an idea that they have
recently changed their mind about yeah
actually yes I'm not famous for changing
my my mind but recently I've been
working on a book on how how
conditionals work is that if then
statements if something were to happen
what would the consequences be that and
and and until I started really working
on this book I accepted the fairly
standard views of these statements
particularly what I call counterfactuals
where you say if if it were the case you
know even though in fact it isn't that
so what what would then we will then
follow and I I've come to the conclusion
that actually the the standard views are
unnecessarily complicated and that in
fact when you when you really look at
the the the evidence people have been
using and some of it doesn't really
stand up to scrutiny it's I mean there's
these occasions where the kind of
judgments that speakers of the language
make are my
mistaken for quite explicable reasons
and and so I think in fact a much
simpler theory of conditionals is
possible than the ones that people have
been holding it's a fairly technical
example but but I really have changed my
mind about that if you were to choose
one thinker one passive no classic
thinker and who has really influenced
you and also then if you could speak
about cannot become an up-and-coming one
or a contemporary one and that you
really admire and present one of their
ideas well I think it's a lot to be to
be said for Plato actually there and I I
think he had a feel for how the
underlying nature of reality has to be
understood in in terms of the kind of
rigorous structural thinking that you
find in mathematics and logic which of
course logic wasn't very developed in in
his time but I think the his his sense
of what kind of thinking would be
required to to solve philosophical
problems pointed in that direction I
mean what one one very interesting
contemporary thinker of a generation
young the mind it's Jennifer Nagel at
the University of Toronto who's doing a
lot of best work in at the moment in
connecting issues in the in the theory
of knowledge with the psychological
study of the of the mind and and showing
how the way in in which we think about
sort of philosophical thought
experiments about which tests our
analyses of knowledge and that kind of
thing actually depends on the basic
human mind reading capacities and so
she's using contemporary psychology to
to cast a lot of light on what's going
on in contemporary it with knowledge for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institutes of
arson ideas at IAI TV
you